okay so let's get started with today's
lecture this is the second lecture on
physics and formed noral networks last
lecture I introduced pins to you and uh
this lecture and also um half of the
lecture on Wednesday next week is all
about discussing the limitations of pins
and also the extensions and like I
showed you there are so many hundreds of
extensions of pins and it's an entire
research field by itself and and so
we're going to delve into some of these
that that improve the perform perance of
of physics and formal
networks so before we get into the
extensions let's recap what a physics
informed nor network is so this is the
key slide from uh last lecture and it
has all the concepts behind pins in this
slide so I'm just going to spend some
time just recapping what a physics
informed new network is
so um physics inform formal networks are
ways to solve differential equations um
or sated to differential
equations and so the example in the
slide here is the damp monic oscillator
which we looked at last
lecture and the key idea of a pin is
very simple it's just to use a neural
network to directly approximate the
solution to the to the differential
equation so pins work for many different
differential equations not just uh the
Harmon oscillator thing here and and
this is what we always do we we say the
noral network which is just a flexible
function that takes as input the the
coordinates of the of the solution so in
this case just the time coordinate
because it's a 1D
problem and then the output directly
approximates what the solution value is
so this U here which in this case is the
displacement of the
oscillator and typically the network
we'll start use start with is a MLP a
simple fully connected Network for
example and it's really important to
note that this is a meshfree approach
and that means that once once we've
trained this network we get a function
as as the approximation to the solution
which we can query at any point in the
domain so this is um different to how
for example finite difference methods
work where once we've run the simulation
we get the the solution on a finite um
Point um on a mesh so discretized on a
mesh okay and then the loss function
that we used to train the network has
these two uh main components the first
is called the boundary loss and that
makes sure that the network matches
whatever the initial conditions and the
boundary conditions we have um of the
problem so in this case we're going to
make sure that the oscillator starts at
a displacement of one and has a velocity
of
zero and so we just to get the velocity
for example we just take the gradient of
the network for the respect of
time and then the important important
component is the physics loss and this
is minimizing the residual of the
differential equation itself so we know
from the differential equation this left
hand side should equal zero and so we
evaluate all these gradients that we
require to evaluate that left hand side
um using the neural network and we try
and push that residual to
zero so kind of intuitively boundry loss
make sure that the solution that the
network learns is a unique
solution um and the physics loss make
sure that the underlying differential
equation is bed at every point in the
domain so we evaluate this at many
collocation points um these green points
in the domain
here so as I said last lecture this is a
really key slide to understand so has
anyone got any more questions on on the
basics before we move
on hopefully it should be clear clear by
now
okay so yeah I I told you that um pins
are a general purpose technique for
solving many different differential
equations and so this is an example of
using pins in two Dimensions to solve
the 1 D Burgers equation plus is time
Evolution so 1 plus 1
D um and I'm not going to go into this
in detail but um the only difference
here is now we're sampling boundary
points across the whole boundary so
instead of just needing one boundary
point we need
many and uh we sample collocation points
in the entire domain and we explained
that this is kind of an interesting
problem to study because it forms a
shock in the solution um which
traditional numerical methods often
struggle with and and so the pin seems
to perform fairly well in this
case and then last lecture I talked
about um all the different types of
problems that we can solve um using pins
and we we we can not only solve forward
simulation tasks but we can also solve
inverse problems where we're given some
observations of the solution and we want
we want to understand what the some
underlying parameters of the
differential equation are these five
five parameters here so for example in
the damp time monic oscillator it could
be understanding what the um coefficient
of friction is or the or the spring
constant and the way that we can solve
these invest problems is that we we have
this extra data loss term where we match
the networks output to the to the
observe data points that we have and
then when we're training the pin we do a
joint optimization where we both learn
the parameters of the pin Theta and the
underlying parameters of the
differential equation f um jointly in in
the same optimization
algorithm um and then you can take this
concept further and even try and start
to learn the underlying differential
equation by learning the individual
coefficients for each term in the in the
differential equation and so this is how
we can use pins for equation
Discovery so in this case we have fire
here now is is a is a vector or a
library of of differential differential
operators um for example all the
gradients that you might think would
appear in the differential equation so d
d by DT d by DX
Etc um and then Lambda here is a matrix
which has contains all the the
coefficients of that of that uh
PD and we we typically so we do the same
thing as in inversion we we match the
network to some observed values of the
solution and we jointly optimize the the
coefficients of the PD here to try and
learn the the underlying differential
equation now this this problem is is
often very osed because there are many
different combinations of PDs that the
data could fit potentially so we often
add like a a regularization like a
sparity constraint to say we want the
equation that has the minimum number of
terms to uh to be the one that we
choose
okay so we're on the second lecture of
of pins limitations and extensions um
like I said I'm also going to do half of
the next lecture is also going to be on
extension zi pins I'm going to give half
of that lecture and then Sid's going to
come through come halfway and give the
rest of the
lecture um he'll talk more about the
theoretical aspects of
pins then we're done with pins and we'll
move on to another big Topic in siml for
scientific machine learning which is uh
operator
learning okay so I've just explained
that
um so I'm going to uh first in this
lecture just talk about the limitations
of pins we've we already touched on a
few of them last lecture um and once
I've given you what those limitations
are then I'm going to spend the rest of
the lecture telling you about uh how we
extend pins to overcome those
limitations and the one that I'm going
to cover in this lecture is mostly
focused on the computational cost and
how can we um make pins faster to train
and this is a really important thing to
be able to do
by the end of next lecture I'll give you
a summary on the kind of realistic re
cases where you should use pins and
where you shouldn't use pins and you
should have a good idea of of when
they're the best technique to
choose so yeah you should be able to
understand the advantages and
disadvantage of pins by the end of these
lectures and um also in these lectures
there's a lot of current research on on
physics and form networks so you should
be able to have a fairly good idea of
the the current state of the art in in
pin research by by the end of
this okay so let's just recap the
advantages before we talk about
disadvantages and I talked I talked a
lot about the advantages last
lecture um so here's a list of some of
the biggest ones um as I've been trying
to say pins are pins are different than
kind of traditional finite difference
methods for example because they're mesh
free and this this means that we don't
have to generate a mesh when we're doing
the simulation and I told you in the
course introduction just the act of
defining a mesh in your computer program
can take humans like days or weeks
depending on the complexity of the
simulation so being able to not do that
step is is a big Advantage if if the pin
Works another big advantage of pins is
that they can jointly solve these um
forward in inverse problems at the same
time so I was I was telling you how we
solve an inverse problem with a pin We
join optimize the Theta values and the
underlying parameters at the same time
this is kind of different to how we
traditionally solve an inverse problem
where we'll have a forward simulator and
we'll differentiate uh we'll get
gradients of that that forward simulator
so in this case we don't have to
differentiate through the forward
simulator which can take a lot of time
to to
do um so often they're they're best
where we have these situations where we
have some some observations of of the
data but we want to understand what the
solution is um and maybe we want to
understand what some underlying
parameters are as
well one thing I didn't mention is is
pins also have tra track tractable
analytical solution uh solution
gradients which um this is uh sometimes
overlooked but actually quite useful so
this just means that we can evaluate du
by DT and du by DX you know the
gradients of of the solution with
respect to its inputs and this can be
very useful for doing for example
sensitivity analysis studies on how the
simulation might change depending on
some
inputs um and they're mostly
unsupervised if we if we think of pins
from a machine learning perspective we
have this PD term which is an
unsupervised regularizer and so we can
actually get away with training pins
with very little data and this is very
different to these like big data uh big
data regimes or or ideas of training
models okay so we'll talk about the
limitations so there's there's three big
Li ation that I'm going to cover the
first one is computational cost and and
I gave you a hint of this last
lecture I showed you an example of pins
solving the wave equation uh again we
have like a an earthquake or explosion
in in some in the earth so in some which
we model with a velocity
model and the wave field it propagates
outwards and causes Reflections and
Etc um and this wasn't a wasn't a very
Network it was only or like 10 layers
thousand hidden units like that's not
massive compared to today's billion
parameter
models but even just training this
network to solve this simple kind of 2D
problem it took an hour to train on a
GPU and and the finite difference
simulation would take probably about a
minute or or less to run so this just
this just isn't competitive with with a
numerical technique uh in this
form
um the real killer is that once we
changed the initial condition and so if
we try to simulate a source that's to
the left or to the right or maybe we
change the frequency or something like
that uh the pin has to be retrained for
every new initial and boundry condition
so so you know every simulation you run
you're going to have to retrain a newal
network okay so that's a big limitation
so let's let's talk about another
limitation and this is the sometimes
poor convergence of of pins and it's not
guaranteed that the pin is going to
converge um to the Minima of your loss
function and this goes back to our
introduction to deep burning course
lecture where we talked about all these
error sources so you know the finiteness
of the training data the approximation
error of the network and the optimizer
like the optimizer not might not be able
to navigate the complicated loss
landscape of the that we're using to
train the
pin start um one of the biggest factors
when specific tyly when training pins is
is this issue of how to choose these
Lambda
values so I mentioned that the Lambda
values are very important because they
control the balance between the boundary
loss and the physics
loss so for example if we if we choose
lamba to be too small in this in this
particular loss
function it means that we won't we don't
care so much about the boundary
conditions and we're only going to
minimize the PD
residual but that's dangerous because
that means the network could learn any
particular any any particular solution
of the of the pde and it might not be
the one that we want given the boundary
conditions that we
have um in the opposite if Lambda is too
large then we're not going to satisfy
the underlying differential equation and
the boundary conditions might just be
imposed everywhere in the
domain um so I've got an example of this
uh this is again using a physics
informal Network to solve the wave
equation now we have a point source
that's propagating through this uh uh um
velocity model here which is just a
couple of Gans basically G Gan
perations and you can see the W field is
like uh just propagating through these
different pertubations and kind of
squashing and changing its shape based
on those
perturbations and this is the PIN so the
top top row here is the BR truth finite
difference modeling uh output the middle
row is after I've trained the pin after
the you know after the final training
step this is this is what the pin looks
like and at first glance it looks like
it does a pretty good job at estimating
the
solution but what's interesting is if I
look at the the loss curve as a function
of training step so what I'm plotting
here is the is the test error so this is
the difference between the pin solution
and the ground truth solution um
averaged over all the all the points in
the
domain and it's very interesting to see
that um whilst it does converge at a
fairly low um absolute error
halfway through training the loss is
still incredibly high and if you look a
bit further it's very spiky as well it
so what I would interpret this as is is
the PIN solution thrashing around it
it's trying it's really trying to figure
out what the solution
is and so it's it's interesting to plot
the the pins uh prediction of the
solution at training step 20,000 so this
is like here before it started
converging what you can see is it's
learned the boundry condition well but
then the rest of the domain it's
basically set of solution to
zero so anyone got any ideas why why
this is zero here why it hasn't even
started putting amplitudes
in
yeah maybe
yeah yeah that could be a reason it
could be
initialization yeah that's a good point
um so why is it a a local Minima in the
loss
function yeah yeah yeah you're you're on
the right lines there's there's another
reason that's related to that
yeah exactly yeah yeah so you've got it
so so if you go back to the wave
equation um uh a trivial solution of the
the wave equation is that U equals Zer
everywhere like this satisfies the PD
constraint it will give you exactly zero
in that in that physics loss
term so my intuition my guess here and I
think it's correct is if you think about
the PD term in this whole part of the
domain you know from this time Point um
further further the PD loss is basically
zero so it's very happy that it's
minimized that turn um the only problem
is that there's some disconnect with the
boundary condition um you know just
after the just after the boundary
condition the PD res will be fairly high
but overall the the L function is fairly
well satisfied so that is definitely a
local Minima if you think of it that
way um so this you can see how this loss
landscape is quite difficult and uh you
know non-convex to
optimize okay um the final limitation
um and it's related to the poor
convergence is is the our ability to be
able to scale pins to more complex
problems so so everything all the kind
of applications that I've been showing
you so far I would argue have been
related to what I would call very
simplified or toy problems so for
example you know waves propagating
through just simple horizontally layered
Media or maybe the fluid flow past a
cylinder this is kind of a canonical
problem that we study in fluid dynamics
but if we talk about having you know a
significant impact in the world and
having kind of real world impacts what
we really want to do is solve these like
large scale problems that people that we
care about so you
know understanding or predicting how the
whole climate system evolves or for
example how earthquakes propagate
through the whole state of California
like if we could be able to solve these
problems faster and more accurately this
would have a massive
impact um but there's a massive
difference between left hand side and
the right hand
side and if you think about our
traditional methods that uh we would use
to solve these kind of larger scale
problems it's often really challenging
to scale them right this is why we're
thinking about using machine learning to
help especially when we have multiscale
multiphysics uh systems if we have large
or high
frequencies um and if we have noisy and
real or sparse data as well these things
can really make our traditional method
struggle
and I think it's a very valid question
to ask all these siml techniques you
know even though they have some kind of
interesting ways to put scientific
understanding into our ml algorithm how
do they COPE in these settings like do
they scale in the same way or do they
have different kind of limitations and
that that's kind of an interesting
research question to
me so yeah how do how do pins COPE in
this setting so so unfortunately pins
struggle um especially uh in this case
where we want to scale pins to higher
frequencies so so what what I'm showing
here is using a PIN to solve you know
one of the simplest Odes I could think
of du by DX equals cos Omega X right so
the solution is just
sign um and what's interesting to plot
is how the pin's performance as I
increase the frequency of the solution
so as I increase Omega
here so on the top left here is is the
easiest problem where the the frequency
is very low so frequency of one here and
I can train this very rapidly and very
accurately using a pin uh and the pin
only needs two layers and 16 hidden
units and so in total that's around 300
parameters to fit this fit this sine
wave using using a fully connected
network if you look at the loss curve
for this this is the test loss as a
function of training step it's this red
line in the bottom here so again it
converges within a few thousand gradient
descend steps and stays quite a
level but the real issue comes when I
increase Omega and so if I go to Omega
equals 15 so much higher frequency
problem um the same pin with two layers
and 16 hidden units here on the top
right um really struggles to fit the
solution and in fact it only fits maybe
six or seven of the
Cycles so why don't you think that it
can fit any more Cycles in this
case y
yeah yeah exactly so we only we only
have 321 parameters in in this network
and so there's just not enough to fit
all of these cycles of the solution
y yes well yeah absolutely so the the
point the question was doesn't this show
that the network doesn't learn at all
but simply memorizes I so I agree I said
last lecture pins stuff the same issues
uh you know estimation or error issues
as standard noral networks so they still
have generalization error approximation
error optimization error um and we're
not we're not telling the pin that we
expect the solution to be signal so deal
here this is just a flexible function
that's trying to fit to a sign sign
curve there are there are ways to put
kind of understanding of what you think
the solution will be into the pins uh
architecture and I'll I'll talk about
that next lecture which can help
yeah so the only solution in this case
if we're stuck with using an MLP is to
increase the size of the
MLP so this is the plot if you increase
it to four layers in 64 H units and you
can see it learns more more Cycles but
not all of them and I have I have to
push it all the way to five layers and
128 units and this is this is taking 60
you know over 60,000 parameters just to
fit a sign
curve um and even so if you look at the
training ER the test loss as a function
of training step even though it
decreases it's nowhere near as
performant as the as the low frequency
pin so I've got a little animation of
this just to show you show you in a in
an animation and so this is um a pin
training on this stamped harmonic
oscillator problem it's the same as what
I've been showing before but all I've
done here is just increase the the
oscillator's frequency so we're modeling
out to more Cycles here
and uh what's happening is the PIN is
really struggling to fit fit the
solution
so
um okay so there're the three big
limitations I would say a pins the
computational cost especially for
forward only problems for inverse
problems they're more competitive like I
said because we don't have to run the
forward simulator thousands of
times um they can be hard to optimize
because of these competing terms in the
loss
function and they challenging to scale
to larger domains like when we have high
frequencies or multisale
frequencies so that sounds fairly dire
but the good news is that there are many
many pin extensions and and uh there are
many better Alternatives than just
training a fully connected Network on on
the
solution um so as I said before there's
this is a whole research field now in
its own right um and this uh ricey paper
has got over 8,000 citations now of and
and if you go into those there's there's
hundreds or even thousands of
applications and extensions of pins that
that people have
shown so we're going to talk about a few
some selected examples in the lecture we
can't cover
everything so I'm I'm going to move on
to talk about uh extensions for
improving the computational cost and
that's going to be the rest of this
lecture um next lecture I'll talk about
those other two limitations the
convergence and uh the scalability to
more complex problems
okay so computational cost how can we
improve
this so one big idea is is this idea of
conditioning the pin on on additional
inputs um so it's a very simple idea
it's to say um instead of having to
retrain our pin for every new initial
condition or boundary condition why
don't we just add those initial
conditions or other pre PD parameters
that we want to solve cross as just
additional networks to the additional
inputs to the
network so let's think about this
seismic simulation task again and this
is our standard pin where we just the
only inputs to the network are the
coordinates and the time
value and the output is the the seismic
pressure
essentially um so this is how a
conditioned pin might work if we want to
train the PIN to learn across one of the
initial conditions so say that we want
to learn a model that is able to predict
this the output no matter where the
source location is so what we would do
is we would add the source location here
the x and y coordinate of the source to
as an input to the to the to the uh
pin and then once this m network has
been trained we don't have to retrain it
uh on a new source location we can query
at any Source location it will give us a
prediction of the
solution
okay so have
yeah yeah yeah so I'll will answer that
once I've talked about how we train it
but yeah um it's a good
question so uh so this is the L function
we use for the standard pin uh you know
PD residual and boundary conditions and
in this example I just trained the pin
with a a few time steps of find that
different solution is the is the
boundary loss that was just how I
defined it so it's just trained on this
on this red essentially this red time
step here and and it's learning to
propagate outwards based on the PD
loss so how do we train the condition
pin so it's very simple same same loss
function all we do is we not only sample
over the per location points and the
boundary points we also sample over the
sources as well when we're training the
PIN
so let's let's think about the boundary
loss we have to generate lots of finite
different simulations with different
examples of the source location and to
match now because we want to generalize
across the source location so this is
boundary losses now matching the the
Network's output across many different
uh boundary or initial initial
conditions from the finite difference
so and then in the physics loss when
we're remember this is still
unsupervised um to evaluate it or we
need it all we needed before was random
points of x and t now we also just
randomly sample an S value and we make
sure that the physics losses across all
the s value inputs to the
network um does that make sense to
everyone so it's just simply adding an
extra input to the network and training
over
it
um so uh so this is some work that we
did we tried to condition this this
physic for Network on the source
location and we took this velocity model
um which is a more complex velocity
model than I've been showing you and the
white points here show show you the
source locations that we we used as
training uh points so we carried out a
finite different simulation at each y
Point here to get our boundary data and
then we randomly sampled across this
area uh to evaluate our physics loss as
well and then the test the test runs
here that I'm showing are just sampled
from these red points so kind of in the
same distribution but not the exactly
the same um training
points and you can see that the pin does
learn to generalize across the source
location it is allowing us to evaluate
this the amplitude you know wherever the
source is located in this region um
there's some interesting things here so
the pin solution is not uh very accurate
compared to the ground truth actually so
what it does do is a good job of getting
the direct arrival so this like the main
amplitude response of the wave but it
starts to really struggle with getting
the reflections and and I think this is
in part because they're much lower
amplitude than the the direct
arrival um but what it does mean now is
that this pin doesn't need to be retrain
for each of these Source locations so we
can do some interesting analysis with
this now so for example we can say
remember I said you have tract tractable
solution gradients we can say how does
the um simulation vary as uh with the
values of s so what's if I change the
source location how does the amplitude
change is it very sensitive or not and
this is a very interesting question for
for example seismic hazards analysis
when when you want to know what the
amplitude response is at the surface
whether it's going to be a big shock if
an earthquake occurs or not and how
sensitive is that to the the location of
the earthquake
exactly so so this this this type of
surrogate model where we've where we've
uh got a fast kind of approximation of
the solution can be can can be very
useful in in uh yeah in
Industry
okay here's another example of a of a
conditioned physics informal Network
um so this is this is an example of
using a a Depot net uh with a physics
inform constraint and um Sid is going to
talk a lot about Depon Nets and uh Depon
Nets a more commonly known as an
operator learning technique um and he'll
talk about that from that perspective uh
but from this perspective as a condition
pin you can just think of it as a as a
condition pin this this physics informed
Depon
net and so what is the network
architecture um it's just a fully
essentially a fully connected Network
that again gives me a prediction of the
solution of our differential equation
here and it takes in our x and t our
coordinates in our domain but it also
has us a kind of special conditioning
input that allows us to uh you know
condition the output based on some some
function
here that's that's the architecture and
this is an example of using a Depon net
to to solve the reaction diffusion uh
equations so uh this is the reaction
diffusion equation and uh in this
equation you here would represent for
example the concentration of some
chemical reaction as a function of space
and
time um and what we're interested in
doing is predicting the solution with
for different values of this this uh
function here this F
term so the way the Depon works is it
just discretizes this function over over
end points so it takes n samples of that
function into as a vector and that's the
conditioning input to the Depon net and
then the other inputs of these x and t
values within the in within the
domain and uh this paper trained this
Depon net using exactly the the
conditioned pin loss function so you
know a boundary loss and a and a a a PD
loss and this is the result they get
they these are different examples of
that conditioning function here and this
is the the prediction or the exact
solution in the predicted solution based
on that conditioning
function so I put this example in
because this is an interesting way to
think about Depot Nets and you can
compare that to how Sid will describe
them in in the operator learning
lectures okay so the next way to speed
pins up is to uh discretize their
outputs so this is what a technique
which is quite different um which I call
I describe as discretized pins
um and so what is the discretized PIN so
so the idea here now is to say instead
of having a fully connected Network that
is giving us a a functional
approximation to the solution that we
can query at any point in the domain
we're going to go back to just trying to
predict the solution on a mes of
points so we're going to have some newal
Network um and the the output of the
network is going to be a discretize
solution so a matrix of values like for
example if we want to solve the Burger's
equation here it would be 128 by 256
points and the the network that's going
to produce this solution for now let's
just say that it just has a fixed input
it's just maybe a random number or just
a zero
and from that value it um decodes that
value into the solution so for example
we could use a transpose convolutional
uh architecture to do
that so the process of learning the
weights is then to just to match the
output to the true solution
someh so yeah to be very clear that the
newal network outputs the the elements
of that of that Matrix and now the
solution at those uh grid points and
it's not a functional approximation so
this is the difference
so how do we train train this network in
a similar way to how we would train a
pin and so so we can use a very similar
loss function to to train this network
in an unsupervised way uh just like pins
are
unsupervised so what we do is we say we
we have this output solution here and we
still want to minimize the residual of
the PD of that output
solution and we know that for example
the burgers equation here we have to
evaluate the gradients of the network
with respect to T with respect to
X so here we have a discretized solution
so the way that we can evaluate those
gradients of the of the of the solution
is just to take finite difference
derivatives so we replace our exact
derivatives that we can get from a fully
connected functional approximation to
finite derivatives that we get from just
taking differences on the
grid and it turns out that we can use
this loss function and train this to
match the solution just just like we can
use this l l function to train the
pin um so to be fully explicit when
we're evaluating the derivative of the
solution with respect to time we just
use like a a finite difference on two
elements for
example does anyone have any questions
on that that's a kind of a a different
way of thinking about
this yeah
fixed value
yeah yeah so it so in the simplest case
it's a fixed value and it can be
anything um it doesn't matter what it is
but it should stay fixed it should never
change if you think about the function
that this network this network is
representing it's like a function it's a
vector or it's a function that takes a
here it takes a Scala value as input it
gives you a matrix as output and that
function has some free parameters
but you just think of that as a blackbox
function with some free parameters that
we're tuning to make the output match
the solution of
PDA does that make sense but what if I
were to suppos change the input let's
say would
change yeah would change it in a really
strange way that doesn't make any
physical sense so we're only using the
architecture as a just as a way as a
flexible function we're just hijacking
the fact that it's a flexible function
that we
frame to produce a solution we're going
to change that in a minute so it's going
to make more sense but this is the this
is the direct analog with it as if we
were going to train the
pin
yeah yeah yeah this could be thought of
as a as a decoder for example yeah yeah
but the difference is that this doesn't
have any physical uh the way that I
framed it it doesn't have any physical
meaning at the moment yeah yeah
but you you understand how we replace
the exact derivatives with the the
finite difference derivatives okay
yeah okay yeah so you got it so we're
gonna change we're gonna change it now
um just before that it's actually the
one thing I didn't talk about was how we
make sure that the solution obeys the
boundary conditions so that actually
this is really important I only showed
you the the physics loss here what do
the what does the boundary loss look
like
well we we can't really have a lost
function that asserts the bandry
conditions here because um well I guess
you probably could actually but but a
better way to do it is is just to make
them hard constraints because we can do
that here so we just um add padding
around the outside and we just pad with
the values that we know the boundary
values so for example um we know the
initial condition here that the weight
the the fluid flow should start with a
sign of soal profile so we're just going
to pad the elements here with with a
signos audio function here and likewise
here we're going to pad these values to
be zero to make sure the flow outside
the domain is
zero and you can see that when we start
taking these finite difference
derivatives we're going to be uh
evaluating the derivative against those
padded values and that's is what's going
to constrain or make the solution
converge to the particular
solution so this is kind of different to
uh normal pins because we're having hard
hard boundary constraints we don't have
that issue with the different Lambda
values in the in the Lost function
anymore
yeah uh yes but we don't solve the
numerical method
um uh with like linear
solves because the function that we're
fitting is not like a linear function
it's like a
complicated yeah yeah just for the B
terms yeah so just the Ping was just so
we don't have problem those points when
we yeah do
the AL also that yeah yeah so this you
can see how we're getting closer to
finite difference methods here I guess
the key difference is the function that
we're fitting is like a nonlinear
function so we have to when we train
this we we're
using we still use Auto diff we still
use autoi here to update the weights so
we still using the gradient descent to
actually converge the algorith
yep yeah yeah so this now depends on the
mesh this is a limitation of this method
yeah
okay so as uh someone suggested over
there um what we what is great is now we
can also condition discretize pins just
like we condition uh normal pins and we
change that input instead of being some
random fixed value uh we change that
input to be the parameters that we want
to condition the discretized pin over so
for example in the burgers of you might
want to be able to simulate over many
different viscosity values and uh maybe
many different initial profiles of of
the
flow and it's the same concept of
condition pins where to train this we
use the same loss function uh we just
inside the loss function we sample over
all these different inputs when we
training the network so we'll sample the
the physics loss over different
viscosity values and different uh kind
of initial conditions in the in the
padding of the of the of the
output so now it starts to make more
sense I guess that this is like a a fast
surrogate
model so what's the what's the other way
that you could train this by the way
just forget about this physics loss
function what we have here is a CNN that
takes in some initial conditions and
gives us a discretized version of the
solution what's the other way of
training it
yeah yeah yeah you could so if you're
given examples of this you could try and
learn this instead yeah and that you can
directly learn a map that's a good a
really good
idea what I was thinking of is the
simplest way to train it is just it with
a purely data driven loss function right
you can just generate loads of finite
different simulations and just train the
network based on
those um so what's what's cool about
this method is that this doesn't need
those simulation training examples so we
don't have to spend the expensive
computation to get training data
so this is the uh one of the main papers
that proposes this kind of technique and
it's uh yeah a very influential paper
you definitely should read
it and the example one of the examples
they showed in the paper was doing a
disc a condition discretize pin uh to
solve the Dary flow so this is you know
given um some porous medium so this
could be just a rock with fractures in
for example can I predict what the
pressure is across that media of some
fluid going through the med Med and what
the flux is through through the through
the structure of the The
Rock and uh yeah what's really cool is
that they trained this this so they used
to a more complicated architecture it
was had convolutions and fully connected
networks and other other kind of things
going on but uh um they trained it with
this physics loss so fully unsupervised
no simulation data required only
requires um input per Mobility Fields as
the input that's the only thing you need
to tr to train this to
converge and they're using soell filters
which is just you know finite
differences essentially to to get the
gradients of this uh of this physics
loss so here's some examples of the um
simulation I think this is the
prediction and and the simulation brr
simulation looks like it does a really
good job at at modeling this
clue and they produced a couple of plots
in the paper which are quite interesting
to look at and so
what we're comparing here is is the test
accuracy so you know the the accuracy
averaged over many example
inputs as a function of the number of
training data that we have so um this is
basically the for the unsupervised
discretized condition pin uh this is the
number of uh input permeability fields
that we train it
on and you can see if we train it on
more more inputs then the the error
decreases is nicely which is good they
they also compare it to the data driven
version which is the blue line here so
the data driven version is when they've
generated many thousands of example
simulations uh using ground truth
modeling and what's kind of cool is that
the UNS supervis method is nearly as
performant especially when you have more
training data as
performant than the supervis method so
you don't need simulation data to train
these models it's kind of cool to show
that what's even more impressive is if
you
the network given some input that's
outside of its training distribution so
the the generalization error of the
network say if I give it a permeability
field that has way more channels or or
way more Connections in the channels um
they found that this unsupervised uh
model the discretise pin has better
generalization performance than the the
model that's trained with only data so
the fully data driven model so that's
kind of interesting maybe maybe the
physics loss is imposing more of physics
understanding into the network
somehow
okay so advantages and limitations of
discretized pins uh advantages we can
now start to use fancy architectures
like CNN to learn the inputs and outputs
and we can extend them to regular
geometries we can even do time dependent
versions of these with rnns um but the
the limitation is that they require
approximate gradients and we we only we
fixed the the mesh that we use we can't
change the
mesh okay I've got one more one more
slide to show you before before we
finish and um this is uh training pins
with finite differences so the main
reason why pins are slow to train is
because we have to compute these
gradients the gradients of the output
with respect to the coordinates and I
showed you last lecture that takes a lot
of time to do so the idea here is to not
use aodi to get those gradients but
instead use finite difference uh meth
methods to approximate those
gradients um and you can get kind of two
to four speed UPS just by doing this but
the downside of this is then you're
using approximate gradients and this
choice of a this like width of the
filter is is a very important
choice okay so um I've covered just the
first extensions of pins which improve
the computational cost uh next lecture
I'm going to talk about improving the
convergence and then also the
scalability to higher frequencies
so yeah thanks thanks for coming see you
next time